I have a baby in September so I've got a
baby for a month no job pulling my hair
out
I get the Carvey gig that's a big gig by
the way now show me and Harvey and it
was to New York moved us to New York
because there's a 13 show guarantee so
we moved to New York got an apartment
and the guys working on that louis c.k
it's a legendary group of people who was
it we michael smiles exec who is it
Roger triumph against old and was
Conan's first exactly amazing guy
comedies leaks out of him it was you
smile Lulu cheek a head writer of course
Dana Carvey funniest guy like me next
show Network well listen the first show
goes on the air and Dana Carvey is
playing Bill Clinton and we're right
after Home Improvement I mean which is a
great show super like very
family-friendly and at the time it was
the number one show is better ratings
than Seinfeld it was like 25 million
people numbers you never see any more
right and Dana is dressed up as Bill
Clinton and he's got working teats like
dog teeth on his chest and he's
breastfeeding puppies and kittens yeah
and something like 10 million people
shut off the TV immediately and they
never came back isn't it shocking and
the next day Dana came in to Steve
Carell and I shared an office together
along with spike feresten and Steve
O'Donnell it was amazing machine pool oh
yeah and and he walked in he goes hey
guys I'm sorry I've ruined your career
Wow you both should but you both should
have been on SNL and I've ruined that
for you and I'd like to apologize and
I'll do my best get you jobs after this
why was it cuz he was like we're
canceled he knew why it's unbelievable
on air for six more episodes it's
unbelievable how they can track stuff
like that and you knew he was right I
didn't I didn't know we were like no
Dana was great we didn't know